in the upcoming comics logic data
science program we will focus on data
science skills that are utilized in
biomedical research as well as industry
the goal of this upcoming webinar will
be to cover some of the background
information including what types of
projects and what types of challenges
we'll be talking about and some aspects
of exploratory data analysis summary
visualization of data data mining and
machine learning every step of the way
there are explanations about what the
methods do and provide a variety of
options for a category of methods
so essentially reprobation
logical maps of analysis help make sure
that there are logical steps and each
method is explained with inputs and
outputs resulting in highly reproducible
workloads after the data is prepared we
will be talking about how to utilize
statistical properties of data to make
sure we spot trends and understand how
to prepare the data for analysis for
example we will cover different
visualization normalization techniques
how do we leverage them visual
information that we have in these
methods and how do we understand the
application of these types of
visualization techniques to help us
understand the data that we're dealing
with
later on to talk about other types of
exploratory data analysis tools and
other types of data visualization so for
example we'll talk about distribution of
data and find associations and
correlations between replicants so we'll
talk about what part of it is technical
noise what part of it is actually James
pression then we'll talk about how to
use regression to spot more complex
trends so we'll talk about how to use
the regression to spot complex trends
that go beyond just a comparison of two
different conditions and move on to
clusters how to understand the different
linkage methods distances and how to
understand the relationships between
clusters as well as a variety of
different types of clustering methods
the omnilogic training program will
cover a variety of methods for
high-throughput data processing analysis
and visualization will help you apply
these methods to clinical research and
pharmaceutical projects will prepare you
and help you design and plan the
analysis to make it impactful build up
your portfolio of projects and analysis
examples understand biomedical research
and read publications critically and
finally you'll be able to obtain a
certificate of completion to approve
your support the program itself will
spend two months of hands-on training
where you will meet twice a week to
discuss these different methods and
projects and then another month and a
half to spend on your own project
preparing the analysis designing the
analysis and being ready to apply the
skills that you've obtained throughout
the program to the data set of your own
[Music]